bonsoir diagonale l'actualité
internationale du jeu d'échecs quarts de
finale du championnat du monde de fidea
avec éloi roland je me sens la loi
bonsoir stéphane bonsoir à tous et
bienvenue dans diagonale spéciale show
pas du monde avec un invité d'honneur à
l'invité d'honneur luc berney bonsoir
luc financère stéphanois soirée loi
alors à noter nous que tu as à
participer à la leçon la semaine
dernière et tu a proposé une très belle
leçon sur le gambit moi que tous les
internautes ont vu je suppose
voilà c'est pour contrer la défense
sicilienne c'est ça exactement une
défense active
enfin une attaque très dynamique voilà
donc lui qui est un professeur hors pair
on va dire y aurait donc ce soir il va
pouvoir nous expliquer où est tout à
fait c'est un tueur de grands maîtres
avec son fameux gambie - il en a gagné
beaucoup beaucoup et en revanche là ce
soir on a vraiment beaucoup de chance de
l'avoir puisqu'il est en ce moment même
en train de jouer un tournoi et vient de
terminer sa partie donc il ya à peu près
une heure de cela il a gagné et donc il
est venu directement la diagonale pour
commenter avec nous ce championnat du
monde alors je suppose que tu as suivi
ce championnat demande comme nous tous
et donc tu as vu les parcours
fantastique
des favoris finalement parce qu'on se
retrouve avec quasiment que des favoris
en finale
oui malheureusement les français ont été
éliminés c'est un peu décevant on
espérait un peu mieux 2 mai néanmoins
tous les favoris sont là peut-être à
part peut-être le champion du monde en
titre qu'alexander talisman
ouais mais qui a été dit n'est pas par
n'importe qui le croient et espèrent ils
doivent envoyer leur effectivement
alexander qualif man le champion du
monde en titre a été éliminée ça y est
c'est fait puisqu'ils affrontaient
l'indien viswanathan anand tête de série
numéro un grand favori de ce tournoi
ouais donc en quarts de finale quant au
numéro trois mondial enfin de même
numéro 2 d'après la fidh et vous
n'auriez numéro deux mondial il a été
éliminé donc oui c'est en huitièmes de
finale
anand kalichman null null dans les
parties longues pour la première fois
que l'espagne arrive à tenir avec les
noirs c'était pas évident parce que pour
la première fois à nantes ne gagne pas
sans match dans les deux premières
parties
oui déjà il pousse à nantes dans les
départager en plus qualif man contre
allende avait un score déplorable avec
les pièces noir puisqu'il avait perdu
les trois dernières parties donc nulles
nulles ensuite première série de semi
rapide encore nul assez facile pour
kalichman qui en quoi le contrebandier
marshall nuls également dans la suivante
où kelly plein et les blancs et féline
donc on arrive dans la série de parties
de 15 minutes et la finlande
plante une très très belle partie ils
arrêtent de jouer aux quatre à bichat
interne en voyant que ça ne passait pas
joue des 4 et gagne une très très belle
slave avec sept fils de pièces et ainsi
de suite
une très très belle partie donc annonce
est qualifiée kalichman est éliminé dure
loi de ce système élimination directe
alors dans la deuxième d'un deuxième
quart de finale adams a pas fait de
détails par face à topalov victoire
d'adams ça ne pouvait s'attendre quand
même là c'est logique donc c'est le
retard prévisible
on peut on peut dire ça comme ça mais je
crois qu'il y avait quand même des
supporters des deux côtés
ces matches où tu fais un match
équilibré peut-être topalov avantage aux
hommes ce conte une raison assez simple
à mon avis est que topaloff est très
fighting gagne beaucoup de partis mais
on perd beaucoup
alors que dams lui n'en perd
pratiquement jamais un pays pas hyper
passé exactement ce qui s'est passé il a
ramassé le point avec les blancs dans la
première effet nul tranquillement dans
la deuxième voilà donc la assez vite
finalement c'est le premier c'est le
seul match qui s'est décidé dans les
deux premières parties avec une victoire
d'adams 1 à 0 sur les deux premières
elle a ensuite il y avait notre français
et notre français kazakh
il s'agit de vladislav quatre chefs dont
le français d'adoption bien entendu
puisqu'il est encore khattak
vladislav tkachiev qui jouait contre la
révélation on peut vraiment parler de
révélation stéphane de ce tournoi c'est
alexandre gris tchouk way le jeune russe
qui n'a que 17 ans donc là je détiennent
la crau et de porno maria off alors lui
qu'est ce que déjà tu connaissais ce
fameux gris tchouk j'en avais entendu
parler mais j'avais pas encore regardé
de ces partis et il est impressionnant 6
4 elle n avait pas perdu pas partie mais
pour l'ac milan n'a toujours pas perdu
oui et en plus il ya toujours premières
invaincues dans un tel championnat c'est
pas facile
à noter qu'il a également battu laurent
frayssinet oui on peut le doigt qui
s'est passé pas mince espoir à faux pas
c'est vrai que laurent maintenant un
troisième joueur à jouer junior bientôt
troisième d'une hormone ya je crois un
prochain classement alors c'est possible
espérons le pour laurent de te
l'apprendre est détruit donc voilà
likhatchev de jooks étaient d'accord
pour faire des semis rapide donc ils ont
fait deux nuls rapide dans les parties
longues
ouais cherchant à se reposer de quatre
chefs ça lui avait bien réussi puisque
avait gagné tous ses matches en semi
rapides et là malheureusement il est
tombé sur un os puisque great shukla
proprement massacre et d'ailleurs où on
verra cette semi rapide oui ou lors du
deuxième semi rapides ou de cap chez
apple et noir eh bien il n'a pas réussi
à tenir son roi s'est retrouvé affaibli
mais ensuite que deux chocs très
technique a transformé son inventaire ça
c'est quand même en retard peu attendu
au hédas peut être quatre chefs essayer
de neutraliser son adversaire en semi
rapide pour se réserver pour le bit ou
c'est un grand spécialiste ou alors on
dit ça mais le problème c'est qu'il n'a
pas réussi encore en faire une seule
ride
oui ben fahd ketchup ne va pas s'en
plaindre puisqu'il a été caché tout le
temps là effectivement
exceptionnellement il faut se plaindre
de pas avoir eu recours au blitz en tout
cas notre française et kazakh quatrième
a été éliminé par get choc mais on peut
dire revanche si quatre chefs étaient
arrivés en demi-finale bon ça aurait été
une demi surprise mais fait que son
guide tout comme demi-finale ça c'est
une grosse surprise quand il s'est fait
dans les angles où il a le même âge que
marco antonio falloir pourtant ces
deux-là etienne bat qu'on le connaît pas
filer français et ponomareff on le
connais parce qu'il est extrêmement
forcée de ses huit titres des plus
jeunes grands maîtres au monde donc tout
simplement may cry tchouk très peu connu
finalement il avait cédé il avait c'est
très bien illustré à nouveau new york
open je crois qu'il a dû être champion
du monde junior enfin il est vraiment
pour des phénomènes à 2606 2616 j'ai vu
un classement où en fait qui n'est pas
du tout en relation avec le niveau qui
montre ici en tout cas on est à peu près
le même classement cannes d'accros oui
mais c'est exactement tout avaler mais
alors donc à noter que sur dans ce
tableau là il y avait donc morose et
beach et ivantchouk des conneries chose
n'a pas pu jouer aucun des deux
puisqu'il a joué contre les vainqueurs
j'ai besoin des deux ces deux joueurs là
oui c'est à dire que great choc est en
forme mais n'a pas sorti de tête de
série on peut détailler son parcours il
a battu à lima au premier tour limaces
et le joueur d'amérique du sud alors je
sais plus exactement quel quel pays
ensuite il est battu c'est marine
israéliens après donc le parcours s'est
continuée qui at il battu il a battu
sert peur voilà il a battu des joueurs
en s en fait si je me rappelle bien
puisqu'il a battu certains us marines et
lgv est et lima donc deux joueurs en
reste et finalement maliba quatre chefs
donc à noter que chris shaw qui est
évidemment maintenant ils étaient déjà
au tour d'avant le seul joueur qui vient
du premier tour voilà donc ça on peut
encore le rappeler puisqu'il ya certains
joueurs donc on en a même beaucoup il ya
72 joueurs qui viennent des premiers
tours il ya
28 tête de série exactement quarante
secondes
il était qualifié en tant que junior
comme etienne bacrot exactement tous les
juniors à plus de 1600 étaient qualifiés
à ce championnat du monde donc rude choc
parcours pas flanc bon puisqu'il n'a pas
sorti de tête de série n'a pas affronté
des joueurs extrêmement fort mais quand
même toujours là très solide il a perdu
aucune partie pour expliquer et il va
devenir riche là parce que la 1/2 finale
ça commence à aller d'aspères des ces
armes axe de cessionnaire donc c'est
vraiment super alors alors donc matches
suivants dernière carte dernier quart de
finale c'est alexei shirov
contreviennent guinea barrière alors
yevgeny marief a fait un très beau
parcours
c'était une seconde de vladimir kramnik
dans sa tandis que les seconds en face
un beau parcours
même s'ils étaient fatigués bon je ne
tiens pas réussi à passer le premier
tour
non mais quand ton super leitao qui a
fait un bon parcours et leur apprennent
à éliminer un autre français auquel
imineo n 2 français licorne nataf le
match reader est donc barrière qui était
un autre second dans deux chroniques lui
arrive donc à ce niveau la compétition
contre alexei shirov qui fait partie
vendant des gros favoris avec un arbre
et adams et la baie au forceps on va
dire on va être vraiment parce que là il
est moche iran frank scherer fait très
chaud dans la première partie il s'est
incliné
donc piteusement il s'est fait
proprement massacrés par marc eev avec
son fameux style faille 4 l entrée est
très calme très posé
le style de barillet le style de mariage
bien sûr donc je les repère la première
ou la deuxième idée les blancs et la
superbe partie superbe démonstration 1-0
en 28 coup c'est la partie du jour ce
sera le gros morceau de cette émission
c'est sur leurs parties de chez rough
contre bas relief
et puis il fallait il fallait la sortir
parce que maintenant battant shearer
quand on est mené comme ça c'est
vraiment un combattant et il est
impressionnant shirts et un topalov en
plus fort je pense qu'on peut mais on
peut voir ça comme ça bref en plus et
donc ensuite semi rapides et la girafe
ne laisse aucune chance à bas relief
simplement il gagne la première des semi
rapides effet nul le dans des pentes on
rappellera que la préférence ni rapide
puisqu'il a gagné le grand prix de senna
et le grand prix de bordeaux
c'est un spécialiste du circuit
diagonale donc shirov qualifiés donc on
vous récapitule les qualifiés anand
adams et great food shirov la grosse
surprise c'est gris tchouk allemande
adams et shirov sont les favoris donc on
commentera à la fin les pronostics mais
ça me dit samedi
ça m'a dit on vient d'associer demi
finale on voit revenir sur ces cartes
parce que le bon mais très belle partie
donc on va voir cette partie entre
alexei shirov et ian binnie bas relief
c'est la deuxième chiron fait mener 1 0
ils fonctionnement gagner avec les
blancs c'est chaud donc voilà on va
passer à un mode grand écran je crois
que c'est assez rare des gens qui
perdent la première partie dans ce
championnat et qui arrive à revenir au
score
la seconde je crois c'est arrivé une ou
deux fois maximum oui c'est arrivé
également à suivre l'air contrit
peng ouais je suis la reine l'a noté que
ça n'arrive que porte il ya un joueur
qui est gros favoris qui a perdu la
première avec les noirs dont il
bénéficie des blancs dans la deuxième
sinon ça arrive jamais ces arrivages
peelman aussi laisser la place et elle
assure premier tour tout à fait alors en
démarre cette partie on va voir oui
shirov avec les blancs qui démarre avec
eux quatre et mariage choisi une défense
dans son style on va dire solide solide
tranquille les souvenirs quoi aussi
c'est la défense française et on a vu je
crois que dans la leçon il ya une
technique pour oui c'est de jouer avec
et des deux malheureusement je suis
refais ne l'a pas employer il a
peut-être pas regardé oui il l'a pas vu
l'émission de bris mais voilà il veut
seulement on peut se poser une question
que je voulus contre la française mais
enfin on va voir s'il joue pareil on va
voir lors des quarts logique on occupe
le centre et la d56 logique aussi et ça
il choisit voilà le grandes variantes
avec cavale et ses 3 c'est la variante
classique qui compte qu'ils attaquent le
centre et protège depuis quatre cents
coups développement normal c'est le sait
l'une des variantes principal une des
principales d'autres coups sur le
possible
donc ça c'est pas la vina vers ça alors
non la flaveur sa dépendre de chabwa où
les noirs à ses dépend de ce que je vous
demande et les noirs choisissent de
jouer cavalier 6 donc ça c'est pas une
vie mais voilà donc ça change et c'est
oui alors de l'udc qu'est-ce que tu
joues en fait contre la défense
française quand la défense française
c'est une défense qui m'a beaucoup
endettés et donc j'ai un peu tout essayé
et dernièrement franche ou le très
ambitieux prend des singes et charron
centre laval une décharge de la
française et paradoxalement c'est une
c'est une quelque chose qui a la
réputation d'être très peu ambitieux
pourtant ses meilleurs résultats contre
la française sans avec cette ouverture
à noter que l' avantage de jouer à
vendre des changes la salle on fait
vraiment une parenthèse complète sur le
champion né sait que l'adversaire ce
sans opposition
plutôt bizarre puisqu'il a un adversaire
qu'elle est blanc et qui se met
apparemment à jouer pour le nul
donc il sait pas trop comment il doit le
prendre il sait pas trop s'ils devaient
essayer de faire nul ou essaient de
gagner et donc finalement il
s'embrouille tout seul ce qui permet
donc à lui que d'encaisser les poings
dans les cités et non pas seulement à
luxeuil alors donc lavernhe classique
après ce coup gabriel 6c voilà fou g5
ses classiques en cloud aux cavaliers
ici le fou qui attaque fort transparence
la dame et les noirs les blancs menace
peut-être de jouer le coup 4,5
oui tout à fait dans ce cavalier me
voilà donc là évidemment barrière donc
varier ses pieds au point de 4,7 à
norman qui évite valence éditions à
noter que tous les autres sont possibles
car les points 4 donc là évidemment le
cavalier est en prise mais ce n'est pas
grave c'est pas grave puisque font ici
attaque la dame dont qui est plus
important c'est quand même plus
important effectivement et là coup
logique fuoh cette voie là on enlève
tous les courages noufou le fouet
derrière le cavalier tranquille pour les
noirs alors là il ya un geste très
technique de la part des blancs c'est à
dire qu'on voit que des échanges de
caisse sont inévitables dans les coûts à
venir des cabinets sont aux prises et
les fous sont sur le point de s'échanger
donc on ne prend pas en rêve 6 avec
lecavalier mais avec le fou j'ai eu
beaucoup de mal à comprendre ce qui se
passait donc on peut peut-être montré de
trucs on va remontrer food rend fou
prend le monde parce qu'on va pas casser
le rock et voilà et maintenant l'idée
c'est donc qu'on n'a plus le fond j'ai
100 mais le cavalier ou 4 à la place
lecallier ici lecavalier n'est pas
attaqué on peut donc continuer à sortir
ses pièces en dix ans le cabillaud 4
exceptionnellement malgré le fait que
pelé sursaut ouverte et plus fort
qu'elles choisissent donc on peut le
prendre quand on veut bien au centre on
s'est volontairement la perte de four
voilà - millions soit ce cas mais pour
l'instant c'est vrai qu'il ya et puis
ville tout de suite il peut toujours
s'échangeait contre le décor des gros
inconvénient de la française on notera
c'est toujours le fou séduite qui en ont
muré derrière ses propres pièces on ne
peut pas sortir à cause du plan
réussisse à leurs pouvoirs soient joués
et b6 soit des fois on peut jouer aussi
le
ou en 17 puis on sait si ce peut-être
c'est les deux plans mais normalement on
laisse se fout c'est vite à la maison
tout simplement
en attendant que ça ça bouge ça très
content que ça se décante mais enfin
vous pouvez regarder l'émission les deux
leçons qui est vu sur la française on
traite un peu de ce genre de position de
l'oms alors là cavalier en f3 logique on
protège le pion des quatre qui était
attaqué par le fauve 6 ici et par là
même des 8
voilà on développe une pièce c'est
l'idéal ça quand on peut développer et
soit défendre son secret une menace au
delà c'était le seul coup d'un seul coup
logique en tout cas à part les changes
des cavaliers pour le faut mais ce
n'était pas l'idée alors qu'à valider
cette alors c'est alors qu'elle peut
être l'idée de ce cavalier qui vais sur
la case 17,1 en général on dit qu'on
veut mais plutôt les cavaliers sur la
coste et 6 mai peut-être là les noirs
veulent jouer le coup c'est simple plus
tard les questions et des réponses donc
non tout à fait des noirs veulent jouer
avec ses 5 et autre avantage de ce qui
veut dire 17 c'est que ça contrôle
stéphane lacaze au 5 novembre pêche les
blancs ici dans un premier temps de voir
lille semaine par exemple un cavalier en
simple contrôle sécurité assez
désagréable et éventuellement ce
cavalier pourra aussi sauté sur la case
ici un fils quand une foule d'objets
c'est très éventuel mais il faut quand
même le mentionne il faut mentionner
alors dam des deux pour les blancs ça
veut dire que la chirurgie visiblement
veut faire le grand roque et
probablement lancer une attaque de pions
contre le contre le tyran qui pose
l'enjeu shirov est obligé de gagner
rappelons le donc effectivement si si je
commence à échanger les pièces rock et
du même côté que l'autre les pions vous
échanger et puis il a fait un nul ça va
aller ça lui va pas du tout cette
configuration donc il est obligé de
prendre un minimum de risques et donc il
va faire le grand roque
d'ailleurs je croit lui que tu joues
dans un club qui s'appelle le grand
roque est exactement je joue grand roque
d'evry un peu mon nouveau club donc vous
êtes obligé de jouer donc je sais pas
peut-être parce que c'est un club où les
joueurs sont des joueurs d'attaqué assez
dynamique donc on a été baptisé le
prog-rock des vraies filles de force et
a donc pas obligé on est fier mais c'est
recommandé
alors petit rock cette fois de barrières
donc là le roi noir donc à donner son
adresse
vous voyez il sera là donc maintenant
les blancs peuvent envisager une fois
qu'ils auront fait probablement le grand
roque
on va le voir un jeune homme c'est une
attaque de pierre ou de pièces ont être
contre le petit rock
à noter une fois de plus grands
principes qu'on a mentionné dans l'eau
pendant les toutes dernières émissions
qui viennent d'être enregistrés d'être
réalisé normalement dès que le cavaliere
si ce n'est plus là tout se prête à une
attaque sur le petit rock donc là on
peut montrer il ya six évidemment bien
fou et c'est un bien moins bon défenseur
qui a canalisé donc là tout est prêt
pour une attaque alors grand raout
logique on y pas mal pas mal du tout un
petit coup de barre ya justement pas mal
on ne sont ni noter que lecavalier 6
était plus là alors mariage ou le coup
qui paraît curieux au premier abord
foods fawcett qui rejoue son fou vous
êtes mais l'idée c'est de libérer la
place pour ce cavalier afin que ce
cavalier soit en défense notamment d'un
codage 7 et éventuellement s'échange
contre eux car ils placent gagne très
fort bas relief est en train de chercher
des échanges
il veut simplifier la position au
maximum alors shirov pour l'instant n'en
a pas curieux ces pièces lors de la
progression de la tacc après g4 g5
il ya des possibilités de gagner un
tempo contre le fou donc c'est souvent
un coup prophylactique en quelque sorte
à leers option viable qui viendraient
ici et après qui a inscrit sur la case
g5 attaquerait ça peut ça peut être dans
l'éventualité alors poussé 4 donc je
développe ses pièces tranquille une case
logic pour le coup finalement pas aussi
peut-être le mettre sur la case d3 pour
viser stockage c'est peut-être possible
oui c'est possible mais ça faire une
collection de la dame et de la tour mais
en général on a plutôt tendance à deux
mètres en c 4 dames est tout simplement
parce que là on sent que les noirs vont
vous bouger leurs cavaliers 17
donc on va mettre notre kf3 sur la case
aux cinq et on veut commencer à mettre
de la pression sur le point sommet le
fou en d3 le coup libérateur c5 est
possible alors que ici si on joue c'est
sain qu'il y a un problème de clouage
devant la case des 8 mai aura tout de
suite ainsi les noirs jouent un follk
oui mais si les noirs ou c5 ici
évidemment le fait l' avantage à voir
les mines le fou sur sept cas c'est que
maintenant on peut prendre ici par
exemple un vélo pliant exactement et tôt
ou tard si ce cas ralliée vient
reprendre ici et bien gagné un pion tout
simplement gagne
pour celles qui connaissent une pièce à
la fin on peut pas prendre ces cinq donc
en fait on peut pas jouer cette voie là
oui sa capture à noter qu'à madame c7 et
noir vont quand même récupérer leurs
pions donc je ne sais pas s'ils
dépensent et sakho aurait été le
meilleur choix sans se marier
évidemment on ne fait pas les gaffes
dubaï joucaviel 6 alors à noter quand
même toujours l'avantagé sur le dessus
cités de fleurs on le voit bien
clairement pour l'instant c'est que les
blancs développer tout leur caisse alors
que le nord-est avec ce fou s'est vite
enfermé et du coup la torah 8 aussi
qu'ils jouent pas trop alors que bell et
blanc pourront ramener leur tour vers le
centre probablement et toutes leurs
pièces vont être en action donc la
cavale f6 logique et normal c'est de
limiter un peu la force des caves et
blanc au centre alors que fesci rentrent
ils choisi voilà mais voilà qui ramène
sa tour vers l'historien jouer lisez les
filles on voit la torah chemin alors on
voit inquiète toutes les questions sont
développés c'est beau ça va quand même
pas c'est superbe c'est beau c'est
propre lire les noirs peuvent se
défendre en essayant de bloquer un petit
peu dans l'esprit du pur isoler la casse
des cinq pour lecavalier ont avec le
cavalier je veux dire à ce que l'on
pourrait venir ici sur cette case
c'est ce qu'il a fait d'ailleurs c'est
ce que fait barrière
voilà faut immobiliser ses pions voilà
enfin il faut on ne sait pas si c'est ce
qu'il fallait faire
ça peut bouger la diagonale à 2 g 8 es
fou ici boucher et permettre je sais pas
peut-être un petit peu anti
positionnelle le coup f7 f5 messi dans
le besoin on en a la nécessité pour pour
se défendre peut-être alors à noter
bizarre le coût est de 7 900 qui
effectivement être serait une faute
positionnelle grave
en général il faut pas jouer le pian et
on rajoute trop tôt oui mais si je
traînerais on est attaqué peut-être que
l'artiste au look on joue souvent le duo
rêve trop tôt donc ça c'est ça c'est
dangereux mais ces dingos le sont ses
derniers conseils ça fait partie du
conseil de nivelles le fun hoplite alors
il l'a alors maintenant que ce quartier
plus en cause 17
on disait alors qu'ils contrôlent et la
case ou 5 et la sueur enfants profitent
un peu évidemment y met son cavalier
maintenant sur la case du samedi pas
deux fois un joueur comme celle de m
pionnier au 5 mai avec de très belles
bêtes sur rov ses ouailles ceccarelli
contrôle énormément de cases dans le
coeur noir
toutes ces cases sont contrôlés ils
contrôlent les rouges et les vertes
c'est pas mal à noter que si les noirs
justement veulent chasser un des deux
cavaliers avec un pion il faut qu'ils
soient f6 soit f5 et là ça sera avancé
le pion f donc l'option eps vii on peut
le montrer stéphane voilà ce pion le
thoumieux alors que je vais je vais y
arriver
voilà il fallait se fier au lycée voilà
ce pion avec 7 rouges qui pourraient
bouger les lignes bougent
le fou c4 se réveille sauf si c'est
gravissime un fou tout de suite avoir
une meilleure action et notamment sur
toi aussi c'est le pion m6 sera faible
pour l'association à faible soutien ici
sera faible donc beaucoup de flèches
mais tout ça pour dire que les cavaliers
sont quasi indélogeable et la monf est
qu'il met la pression il faut pas que
les noirs on craque à bouger leurs pions
parce que ça et non pas trop trouve par
exemple s'ils jouent b6 on peut
envisager tout de suite
ces six sacs gagnerait
une erreur par exemple les six imaginons
que les normes jouber si celui-ci
pourrait avec l'idée de sortir enfin en
fout maison depuis six ans bessette et
mail à quel point c'est probablement
cavale et c6 oui et après dame 17 et
après dame 17
là il ya une multitude de coups
possibles je ne sais pas dans quel ordre
il faut il faudra les jouer c'est pas
évident et bien reprendre on pourrait
prendre le fou ici sur la case de 7
oui ça serait déjà positionné lmnp y est
on voit que les lois chercher une
combinaison en expansion
le fou pour le cavalier ins avec
l'ouverture de la colonne eux mais je
sais pas sûr qu'ils aient une découverte
qui gagne on dirait que j'ai
l'impression qu'il n'y a rien de concret
tout de suite d'ailleurs à noter que b
si c'était peut-être le bon cours
puisque la toutoute échange de pièces
est bon pour pour les noirs c'est un
fait donc c'est pas évident peut-on
alors là si c'était bien varié choisi de
vie le coup le coup qu'on fait trop tôt
barrier a craqué une accra qu'il a il
est vrai qu'il a craqué sous la pression
des cavaliers environ 7 du jouet b6 et
il choisit mais bon il ya peut-être des
partitions v6 avec plein de problèmes
sûrement il choisit le coup f5
alors voilà c'est humain c'est un coup
responsable sa valeur pions oui quand je
vois ce coup j'ai envie de dire quelle
horreur qu'elle aura pas ce que ça
affaiblit les cases blanches
ici ça veut dire que ce fou ici en c4
devient monstrueux tout de suite le pion
aux six ici que je met en jeu alors il
faut crier très fort il faut appuyer
très fort voilà en jaune ce pion
maintenant va être faible puisqu'il va
être sous la prise de la tour ici et
donc il va sur la prise de la tour et du
fou donc il va avoir du mal il est noir
en vend du mal à le tenir
f5 n'est clairement pas un
compositionnel avant d'être heureux
mariage ou essayer d'en haut est de
mettre le fou en f 6
il n'avait pu ne savais pas quoi faire
un probablement fournisseurs tels aux
cavaliers aux quatre voiliers l'autre
l'autre il est évidemment ses dettes et
clio iv et de le déloger
nous les premières oui hélas shirov
alors va de l'avant et je vous prends
alors c'est important ça non parce que
sinon il y avait un coût
il n'y avait pas foule et 5 oui oui tout
à fait on va leur montrer sévère si
chirac joue par exemple cavaliers c5
on va dire y'a surement le coup ici tout
de suite sous les seins qui attaquent la
dame blanche à des endroits qui est
derrière donc on peut rien faire on peut
faire que f4 ou pareil non alors f4 sa
perte tout de suite il faut profiter à
3,6 à amelia pas d'autre choix s'il ya
toujours 3 qui est fort c'est la voie la
tête au roi mais qui perd une qualité
c'est dire qu'il faudrait mettre la tour
devant et d'où l'intérêt de supprimer ce
cavalier il faut le supprimer
donc en fait le coup f5 force quand même
le gars du wakfu qui est dangereux voilà
ouais c'était ça son idée wells est plus
élevé que prévu après fcn
il faut jouer vous prend cavalia il faut
d'abord jouer foucan cavaillon viennent
voir pourquoi cause de la menace des
noirs du fou ici qui menace sur cette
case attaquants
la dame ici et le cavalier ici protège
la case f4 par apple avait un jour f4
voilà on peut pas contrer en jouant le
contre 2,4 donc la piaule prend fou et
la girafe ou un coup caméline c5 très
bien et très bien très bien passé actifs
il ya deux cavalli superbe chien de qui
elle est superbe à noter que il ya deux
cavaliers contre de fou pari de fou il y
en a forcément un quai fort qui est bon
et un mauvais et un quai mauvais c'est
sûrement le fou civic qui est mauvais
voilà c'était bon ça a été bon à noter
donc que s'il le faut cette s'échange
contre n'importe lequel des deux
cavaliers on se retrouve avec un
cavalier contre le mauvais goût donc
pour l'instant difficiles positionne
allemande allait jouer un coup comme
frankie valli pour l'instant alors
barrière choisi de jouer le coup fou gsm
attaquant la dame rouge et 5 à mon avis
n'est pas judicieux non plus comme coup
j'aime pas trop ce coup sa force les
blancs a joué 4 effectivement mes
camarades attendent beaucoup finalement
bah oui et 4 ça l'air d'être un bon coup
il joue quand même f40 effectivement
maintenant on peut le faire
d'où l'intérêt d'avoir su public à venir
parce qu'on voit bien pourquoi est-ce
que normalement il faut forcer les coups
comme f2f 4c pour bénéficier de la case
au cap
quand on peut mettre une pièce dessus
moi mais là les noirs pourront jamais
mais qui sont dans l'incapacité totale
de mettre n'importe quelle pièce selon
qu'ils n'avaient rien pour venir ici
quand il peut faire il fournit une
tournée en asie et puisqu'ils en ont
plus donc forcer un coup commettre
quatre c'est pas du tout un bon choix de
yevgeny borisov donc la foux et 6
maintenant et là je suis prof continue
h3 il veut jouer tôt ou tard le levier
paf vous voyez plutôt tôt que tard mais
plutôt tôt que tard
g4 pour s'échanger le pion f5 et ainsi
libérer toute la colonne ici vers le roi
ouais enfin voir même jauge est sain que
c'était fait nous-mêmes choisissons
étouffer complètement de renoir
enfin on va voir shirov nous a fait une
attaque modèle de toute façon ça va être
une très très belle leçon à 80 de son
attaquant d'amd 6 il sort sa dame il
veut peut-être mariage peut-être mettre
son fou sur la case aussi se protège
cette case peut-être alors oui mais
probablement apparaître puisque
l'épreuve faut aussi s'il y aurait un
cavalier 3 kg 6 qui récupèrerait la
qualité donc on ne sait pas ce qu'il
veut faire
oui oui c'est pas clair non non c'est
pas clair du tout il veut mettre les
tours en raison probablement ouais mais
il va comme l'imagerie son fouet par les
vents et sur laquelle contrôle
ils contrôlent la casse et 6 il a
l'intention de jouer b6 oui oui tout à
fait c'est ça la différence de théâtre
jouée des 6es empêcher d'entreprise etc
avec des cavaliers c6 qui quitte une
fortune faisait rien qui faisait rire et
mais vous mettra détendre mentionné non
mais de toute façon d'amener si c'est un
coup utile de manière générale pourquoi
pas le jouer alors qu'elle ait cédé 3
shirov par avant qu'on ne m'attaque
alors si on revient avec son cavalier et
là on al'avantage ses conseillers la
vallée meuf center changer sears ici il
faut prendre
on peut toujours en place et le cavaly
par un autre mais peut-être y prendre
l'union d'hier seront prendre adduction
ça fait toujours passer quand même
oui tout à fait protégé donc b6 ça il va
sortir en fait sont fous et hormis du
temps quand même
et maintenant on shiro enfin bien
ça a bien pris le sens que là ça y est
c'est lors de ces le signal de la tacle
à toutes les pièces de shearer sont
prêtes
il faut jouer g4 et maintenant up g4
seller qui profitent shirov du dinah tu
veux mettre ton cou de ce côté et bien
dans ce cas là je peux attaquer de le
battre c'est ça en fait ce que ce fou
quand même un petit talent des membres
de toute façon que j'ai quatre étaient
inévitables donc il n'ya pas de l'aïe a
plus de question à se poser de la part
de bas relief
il fait ce qu'il peut pour sortir ces
pièces la taille de girofle et déjà bien
enclenchée il ya beaucoup d' avance de
développement enfin ça y est les pieds
en france vers leurs rangs il faut déjà
dire que la position noir est déjà très
très délicate
c'est travailler fort et sans intérêt à
échanger sont fous ces 8 contre un des
cavaliers un jour fois ci ça soulagerait
cette médiation
cette fois ci ça aurait été envisagée
dès fois 6 sièges et pour les 5 gagnants
champions quand même avec la colonne
joubert qui avait g4 qui revient après
ça devient très très dur très très très
dur alors ces cinq marielle choisi de
prendre les choses à mon sens de
problème c'est que c'est pas lui qui a
la force du centre ouest où il joue
comme ces cinq pour essayer de faire
mais c'est peut-être al'avantage des
blancs s'éprend des quatre c'est pas une
menace je pense rassemblement qui doit
jouer ses cartes jouées c4i s'ils
attaquent ou chasser les cavaliers
lequel il n'y a pas vraiment d'autres
cases bonne que les caisses des trois
donc je suis refait trouver un truc il
commence par jouer g5
j'ai cinq attaquants fou et là où wall
fou décalant déjà une première remarque
si fou prend cavaliers on reprend a
probablement avec le cavalier je dirais
et ensuite vous faites toutes les prises
sont correctes tout à fait tout et plus
encore avec le cas raison que je pourrai
reprendre de la tour du pin
non c'est horrible donc frank hallé est
impossible donc choisi foudres des huit
c'est pas beau c'est très moche parce
qu'un fou ici il n'est pas très bien
parce qu'en plus il empêche toujours les
tours ici d'être en liaison et donc ils
sont toujours sa part a cédé 7 à 8 ou
encore que de la laisser sur le
vis-à-vis de la tour e oui sept non mais
t'as fait je rejoins un joli coup d'
attaque
si on joue le coup dame j'ai deux salles
il a compris science il veut
oui j'ai six mois yam en est avec la
dame ici créer tout ça y est alors il ya
un sentiment fauteuil sur des saints et
commencer un petit oeil effectué enfin
il ya plus important que ça c'est que le
coup ces cinq c4 a été évitée puisque
maintenant il y aurait quatre ans et 4 à
superbe alors en voyant ça si les normes
étonnant joue c4 tout est le fait que la
dame et angers 2 6 ici tout de suite les
blancs pour jouer cavalier prend pions
tout simplement puisque si les noirs
prennent ici
voyez ce qui est fort c'est la dame
pourrait prendre la tour habite à une
autre et encore le fou s'est vite serre
si on prend après le deuxième quart les
et bien on récupère le fou ne crois tu
pas les lois que ce serait peut-être la
meilleure chance des noirs dans cette
position alors je ne sais pas mais je le
prends g5 suivi de fou prend un f4 dame
prend ici d'un promeneur il ya neuf ces
quatre chèques intervient et les dames
ces quatre essais taurine puisque là les
blancs vont échanger vraisemblement les
dames avec des mots six échecs mais même
si on fait d'un point f4 d'abord c'est
le renoir m'a l'air trop fait dans cette
pression qui c'est impossible
ça nous prend maintenant depuis on peut
aussi on prend un fiat c'est de chez 5
oui mais a priori ça va quand même être
dur alors lg2 ces intrus multiples
fonctions samedi de l'ata la dame est
super bien placé ici à la fois un oeil
vers le roi noir et un oeil vers le
centre le pion des scènes qu on peut
peut-être mentionner aussi aléatoire à 8
il ya sans doute une autre menace la sto
place dans cette position c'est de jouer
pions français sanction prend ses 5 et
cavaliers ont suivi deux tours prend des
cinq qui a l'air de marcher donc en fait
d'un g2 c'est vraiment un coup multiples
là il faut être spécialiste
imaginons doucement doucement
imaginons le coup à 7 à 6 effectivement
la voir que tu mentionnes ça serait
pions procès scène
oui tu comprends c'est simple on reprend
le câble est quand même d'en gagner en
bio ils vont combiner faut accepter
sacrifices oui et la tour prend pions
oui maintenant les noirs seraient
obligés de jouer par exemple vous
condamne t systems mas est peut-être
dans la seine pour protéger les voiles à
damas est bon y aurait continué ses six
encore à l'origine d'un v6 pour montrer
l'idée simplement ici aurait tout
reprend fou et après par exemple tout
reprend et bien maintenant dame récupère
la tour ici avec probablement une bouse
mais c'est très compliqué c'est juste
pour mentionner supplémentaire puisque
ici la foulée cette image à l'aide
ouais bon mais c'est une idée une idée
c'est une idée sans qu'ils en aient
cherché enfin réfléchir à tout ça fait
réfléchir à tout ça donc la variable
doit faire attention et d'ailleurs il
fait attention de natation puisqu'ils
jouent tous b8 voilà tu veux éviter que
cette dame ici pointe sur la case avis
la tour ici il a mis ici parce que et en
plus il peut être il veut avoir des
visites et la présidence et 5 voix la
maison pouvoir que 7 tours et du jeu
sont en tous sens le pian soit en cas de
décharge au centre de récupérer la
colonie alors là regardez bien la
position a priori il se passe rien pour
l'instant et dans huit coups bas reliefs
abandonne avec une position une poubelle
vraiment très moche on va très vite
tu vas faire shirov maintenant aider
j'en utilise en attaque hop j-6 alors ça
c'est pas mal alors simplement sa double
intérêt ça à la fois sa menace de
prendre la tête et de libérer ici ainsi
la colonne vers l'europe et aussi si les
noirs par exemple jouent le coup à six
probablement les noirs les plaintes pour
u2 posté un cavalier sur la dépouille
effectivement alors ici ce qu'a dit avec
7 n'a pas l'air extrêmement fort mais en
fait ils l'éolien deuxième cavaliers qui
va dire que c'est déjà le deuxième quart
eli qui va venir ici puis rend toujours
des sacrifices sur le pion à 6 tours ou
tard mais il ya deux cases qui sont
extrêmement forts pour câbler d'une
manière générale dans les attaques
c'est la case f7 et la case e set ces
deux cas ce qui a priori n'ont l'air un
peu anodine on préférait mettre une tour
mais elles sont extrêmement efficaces
là dessus car elle gêne horriblement les
noirs sommes là c'est gagnant tout de
suite à noter que c'est quand même un
coup responsable de la part de shirov de
jauger si ce parce que après h6 la
position des colonnes et quand même
bloqué oui il libère la case f6 c'est
donc en changer six il a quand même
calcul un certain nombre de variantes
qui lui permettent de reprendre d'autres
avantages positionnelle comme la case f7
que l'on vient de signaler et la prise
de la colonne eu probablement qui doit
être importante
info voir qu'est-ce qui se passerait
effectivement après le coup
six s'étaient fait je crois qu'on l'a
dit qu'avec cette camionnette avec
quelque chose de terrible qui s'abat à
l'événement on recrute romain tout
simplement il n'y a pas de casse pour
les dames par exemple sur ces quatre
jours probablement cavalier seul dans la
dalle mais cela testé ces quatre là des
métros prisonniers à mais attention
ambitions on peut pas je me suis garé
non plus à ataq la dame a mis en tension
attention peut-être une sauvegarde bas
et on a ça va aussi dressé ccfa une tour
pourrait venir sur la case aussi
s'avérer la taxe soit mais c'est
terrible c'est assez terrible g6 il faut
pas vous assiste donc la variante
choisie le coup ces quatre îles vous
désorganiser les cavaliers oui tout à
fait pas très objectivement ce cavalier
là il n'a pas trop de quasi là que
lacazette dont on dirait puisqu'en b4y
les emprises de la dame noire puisque
shirov accor a vu plus loin vu plus loin
que nous et alors si fixé à six
cavaliers sur la kz2 la quinzaine à
nantes et nancy bat lescar dans le rouge
si le cabinet valeur gelé car ils sont
un peu désorganisé et peut-être carrière
ça m'a passé lors du mal à revenir en
jeu fera jouer lâche 4 le carrier h3
peut-être oui alors qu'on l'avait déjà
dit en commentant la partie de shirov la
dernière fois où il avait battu donc
qu'ils avaient été battus giflés battu
del fond noir en mettant son cavalier
donc ils avaient le choix entre la
classe c1 ou la case 1 il était allé sur
la casse c'est simple mettant aux prises
mais sa rentrée dans un plan
positionnelle et là c'est exactement ce
que fait shirov alors on va le mettre
sur la case b4 on va voir à béchir jouer
que québec a complètement alors mis
alors inattendu complètement il va ton
café tabac de la part de schirrhein
schirrhoffen et ce alors il met
carrément pris ou et voilà c'est son
principe
bon alors mais ces pièces emprise il
s'en fout il s'en fout ici les meilleurs
car voilà tu montres ses bases et quand
même sur une combinaison pas uniquement
potentiel à noter que tout de suite
quand même bien me placer qu'ils
n'étaient que 2 puisque la menace c'est
probablement de faire d'en prendre des
cinq gagnants pions puisque le cavalier
pour étage gagnant toute la maison voilà
gagnant toute la maison autre menace
c'est sans doute cavaliers c6 est ce que
les noirs ont le choix est ce que parce
que déjà quand il a failli réussir pour
en garder bon si on peut le prendre
c'est sûr mais
tandis que l'as bari va l'accepter on va
voir si on peut s'étendre accepter
pareil on n'accepte pas voir qu'est ce
qui se passe il accepte oui donc la
variable choisi dame prend cavaliers on
a une bonne note à l'agenda fois
catherine aurait pu faire la caisse
voilà on va regarder le round s'il avait
choisi aussi d'aller choisir une dame
prend décembre il y aurait une dame
prendre des 5 par an et chaque courant
tout de suite on va avoir droit à un
petit matin elle étouffe estevan on va
revoir tout ça vous avez probablement
montrer d'invoquer et technique doit
effectivement les fameux cahiers
techniques effectivement alors là roi h
8 serait forcée et la chaire pour jouer
le superbe 4e set
allez on va le montrer encore on va le
retrouver une fois de plus si le s'il
est noir alors ils allaient à leur
première résidence et y apprennent le
cavalier si on prend le cavalier et bien
tout simplement prendre la dame ouais et
tourbier madame n'a cessé tout au 8 nat
essai imparable mouvement conclu par et
sauf si on joue fou des sept merveilles
à toi vite quand même le foot emprise
réduite
non mais c'est à rades de fos est mais
le fou est aussi en prise tout
simplement et il ya maths à tous les
coups
donc à tous les coups on gagne à tous
les coups on gagne donc alors voilà
revenons en donc on ne peut pas prendre
voilà on ne peut pas prendre et donc
soutenir l'euro j'ai vite alors là on va
voir le fameux cavaliers h 6 échecs
double échec alors échec du cavalier et
échec de la dame donc double échec on
est obligé de bouger le roy on a le
choix
donc là le roi vient ensuite le roi
vient sur la case h vite hélas le
superbe d'un an j'ai vite baiser de la
mort puisque puisque la sauvette obligé
de prendre le roi ne peut pas prendre
évidemment puisque le cavalier ici
protège la classe donc il faut propre à
dire ce que tu viens de dire à ton
adversaire
il faut france dans l'intérêt de celle
de tournon avec un poney you de l'or
noir à tous les coups
hélas là le fabuleux cavaliers f cet
échec et mat ça c'est du moins le plus
peut-être le plus moral qui existent aux
seychelles et très pur dans la mesure où
le roi noir ne peut plus bouger il est
pris de part ses propres pièces et au
mur et il est embourbé et le cavaly
faire les chèques tranquille ça
s'appelle le matin à l'étouffée le matin
diplômés contre-preuve préparer
les notaires je crois que c'est un match
qui est très très vieux parce que j'ai
vu une partie des années 1600 je sais
pas combien où il s'effectue le même
matin mais au milieu de l'échiquier
quelque chose d'assez étonnant donc oui
oui c'est bon alors là donc la finale va
et vient de voir pourquoi il ne faut pas
prendre ce cavalier donc baraillé fait
bien fait de pas le prendre évidemment
il doit rien joué le coup fou bessette
mais on voit qu'il a mis du temps
variable non seulement sortir son fou il
a dû jouer la touriste y en a sur la
case b8 on ne sait rien wahid hambli
classe b side en plus n'est pas ils
contrôlent l'actuelle c6 est un plus aux
fouilles et qu'il passif il est que
passifs mais il est obligé de défendre
et il est obligé mais il défend le pion
à noter que maintenant il attaque le tvb
quatre médecins des cavités grèce qui
est attaquée puisqu'il ya plus le les
plus minces alors la chaire fait le coup
puis on prend à cet échec échec on est
obligé de rentrer en q3 et il a ouvert
la colonne pour saddam ça y est la
colonne ici est ouverte
non simplement est maintenant chez rough
par le prix du câble et c'est toujours
son truc shirov il n'aime pas bougé les
pieds s'attaquer non il n'aime pas être
contrarié donc quand on lui a tenu tête
et ne la bouge pas s'énerve alors il
faut pas le contraire
et là ils vont tous reviennent tout
simplement puisque maintenant tout
simplement si d'en prendre cavaliers et
bien ça serait sanctionné par un baiser
de la mort par des éléphants avec dame
pranger cet échec
je crois que tous nos internautes c'est
quand même beau de le signaler alors
donc ce cavalier toujours imprenable et
il faut parer le match parce qu'il ya
quand même le reste de ma titine oui
difficile apparaît d'ailleurs c'est la
façon qu'a par exemple ce qu'on pourrait
jouer il va x 6 x 6 7 quoi te voilà fou
et 6 que se passera-t-il sur fotsis mais
en contrôlerait plus la cage et 6 la
dame pour s inquiète tout simplement la
dame pourrait venir sur la cas sociaux
n'est pas simple puisque c'est pas
encore matt après avoir gelé vite et
imprimera j'ai vite peut-être les
plantes peuvent consolider leur position
de simplement jouer en c2 c3 aussi dire
qu'on voit pas de moyens de continuer la
tacc protège le cavalier le cas mais
peut revenir en jeu et l'aele et blanc
toujours une forte à table le plan
maintenant des blancs c'est qu'ils
essaient doc avait lieu de trois et on
gagne 8,5 de manière qui avait forcé les
tubes qui est d'ailleurs en prise avec
qui est en prise aux qui est en prison
mais qu'on n'a pas spécialement envie de
prendre dans ces conditions mais pas
tout de suite on valoir dans tes droits
il est en ondes années comme on dit donc
il heureux dans que l'avarié fort et
très bien plus je vous le couffo 6 oui
il choisit un autre coup la machine
damages 600 ratag al'inconvénient voilà
mais quels inconvénients de plus attaqué
le québec afin qu'une commune entérine
aussi que les blondes peuvent planter
une superbe fourchette fourchette ici
parfaite la fourchette parfaite
oui ça des chaînes classiques du
cavalier contre les deux tours ça c'est
tous les débutants connaît ça oui c'est
la fameuse fourchette de câbles et grand
maître aussi hélas lors shirov choisi de
jouer le coup surprenant d'un f3
bertrand surprenant mais pas trop dans
la mesure où des grands voilà c'est ça
il défend son public être dans un
premier temps ils laissent passer cet
objet il défend ici deux tours le cap et
la tanger a maintenant menace de venir
sur la casse g6 protégé par le cavalier
on continue de menacer qui a aidé cette
voie là ouais ils continuent de menacer
la case 17 et la deuxième tour va
pouvoir entrer en jeu et un autre des
principes que vous avez dû donner dans
vos émissions probablement c'est la
menace est plus forte que l'exécution
ouais donc là il parlait menace adverse
et continue de créer de nouvelles
menaces pour lui et garder les menaces
qui l'avaient même avant alors
maintenant variés djougou et 6 ça y est
on est on tâche bien maintenant la casse
g7 avec grand fou et il menace peut-être
d'échangés enfin ce cavalier parce que
oui mais a noté que c'est un gros
inconvénient stéphane que ça na pas
parler savamment fait ça n'a pas me
paraît la fourchette et il avait vu mais
une heure ils avaient espéré de suite
manier il avait vu
avait vu ils n'avaient pas le moyen de
s'en sortir donc cavalier 17 quand même
oui et là c'est quasiment terminée d'une
terrible chute lors à noter que quand
même il y aurait qu amélie prend tour
avec qui chaque employé bon il ya ça
aussi
et en plus il va rester avec son fouquet
cette le pauvre marié et père d'une
qualité et autres fermes et le cavalier
à saint louis bonne question luc
lecavalier b4 par le coût est oui oui
effectivement les noirs pour rejouer le
coup à cinq qui alertent de
effectivement d'être très intéressant
oui c'est la partie d'ailleurs assez la
partie c'est la partie ça c'est la
partie
ouais non ah non ça n'est pas la partie
par la partie mais de toute façon ça
donnait à peu près la même chose que la
partie il y avait cavaliers prend tout
de suite et celle là il y aurait
cavaliers prendre un mec échec
voilà ton après deux tours en est qu à l
epr option dessin et mettre son public à
venir au sort en prenant l'option de
derby et on peut pas profiter du cloud a
gelé la sa moulinsart des basiques sont
éthiques à myspace échec voilà tout à
fait qu'elle sonne faux bessette et on
va voir c'est un peu la partie
d'ailleurs c'est un petit peu la partie
car les 17 lâche bailliage choisi le
coutour bd huit attaques en cavalier oui
d'après cavaliers prend tôt et après car
les prend pour roy photo encadrée
maintenant quand même car les prends des
scènes et là il ya un thème barrière vue
il y avait peut-être un petit piège
parce que il joue un coup subtil mariage
les jours où elle suit voilà
effectivement ils joueront ensuite parce
que le cavalier ne peut plus prendre le
fou avec échec ici le cavalier prendre
fou tout de suite et tout simplement si
sanctionné par la prise de la dame s'est
alors qu est ce qui est terrible oui
comment s'en étaient sortis plutôt bien
et dire et s'en sort bien chirens parce
qu'il a il a vu plus loin il sort la
dame du cloud and mason et ils attaquent
une autre pièce il joue le coup dame en
a trois superbes attaques là tout à fait
puisque la dame attaque la tour f 8 et 6
arrière lecavalier et bien c'est la tour
qui pâtit avec l'échec
elle pâtit la pauvre effectivement
voiliers qui après damas 3 c'est terminé
puisque si on ne prend pas là tout va
bien on va prendre le frais et 6 avec
une qualité plus hélas y en a deux un
technicien comme shirov effectivement ça
ne m'échappe pas une jungle ce genre de
position donc pour résumer cette partie
une boucherie je crois que c'est
vraiment une boucherie une attaque
claire du début à la fin et un bas
relief complètement impuissant à
désarmer les bons et noir ont été très
passif dans le quartier raison de bouger
plusieurs fois les mêmes pièces la foule
si leur venue en sept gars et 17 km et
f6 qu'elle ait des cinq cantons mais
aussi qu'elle quelques nerfs durant
fallu gagner cette partie absolument je
lui fais confiance
ok alors bon tout de suite on va passer
à l'élimination de notre français ouais
parce qu'il ya une belle partie je crois
qu'on va voir notre article comment
dresser la partie 13 gretsch au contrat
de quatre chefs
voilà sept ans que la première série de
départage ils ont fait nul à la première
grille tout cas les blancs on va tout de
suite allé wind vers la femme avance et
on va avancer cette partie donc voilà
c'est une partie espagnole
on vous la montre en blitz qui a été
jouée par un gris tchouk avec les blancs
quatre chefs connais très bien cette
variante il avait joué à 3m curieux ce
petit coup à 3,8 et nous condamnerait
pas commenté les clans n'a pas 90 tous
les coups on va te paraît pas le temps
on va arriver ici je fais des fouilles
et défiler les coûts mais on peut
augmenter un peu la partie quand même
voilà on voit que les pièces s'échange
ça a l'air de tenir pour les noirs
salaire très normal oui la voilà up à la
f5 f5 alors f5 ça commence déjà à être
un peu litigieux comme d'habitude on a
toujours le cul rêve trop tôt trop tôt
vous remarquerez que l'on vous choisi
des parties thématiques puisque là c'est
encore le coup qui va devenir
définitivement les pressions du roi
n'aura donc là les bleus en profitent
à noter que le roi blanc lui est très
bien protégé dans cette partie est il
que je garde permet de placer ses pions
à l'attaqué des champions prend g4 qui a
aidé 2 laval alors s'arrête là et des
deux c'est le bon coup ont déjà c'est
une des seules classes du cavalier en
plus il va échanger lecavalier debladis
quatre catcheurs comme les quêtes actifs
il va être obligé de s'échanger et on
voit que laurent blanc lui va pouvoir se
mettre à l'abri ici tranquille protégé
par ses pions alors que le roi noir lui
est complètement à l'air moins bien
toutes les cases au tour lui qui sont
complètement bill et notons donc que si
c'était une finale de tout en les noirs
seraient peut-être un petit peu mieux ce
serait sans doute n'est peut-être légère
avantage noir est réglée damian les
dames et bien la position faible du roi
et ça parle énormément est là et on voir
que le board wri le petit ou 17 ans
et bien c est faire une expérience elle
provient de ce genre de position il est
très expérimenté
donc là il a changé et maintenant il a
une position très technique où il va
falloir qu'il profite de la position
donc délicate du roi noir pour le
harceler et piquer des pions passage
alors il va jouer très très lentement il
va voilà il va profiter de la colonne
eux
alors vient de consolider sa poule et
défend le pion à 6.6 chiappa de pointe
chez les blancs pour attaquer contre oui
dabo 3 un coup totalement anodin au souk
ou des montres à 9,5 et la tranquille en
fait il s'en vend l'abri pour être
première chose ici et prêta nous
prennent part activement l'attend pas ce
qu'il a dit cela je cherche une
forteresse en l'occurrence il essaie de
mettre son roi saddam et sa tour sur des
positions il y aura plus d'échecs et
plus de pions en prison mais ils
n'arrivent pas à la trouver
dabo vite voir que les blancs vont
essayer d'échanger n'étions c'est simple
c'est bien c'est bien on est tout à fait
sûr promotion prend maintenant le rêve
des noirs dans cette position c'est de
jouer ces cinq c4 mais là tout de suite
c'est embêtant balaie tout de suite là
c'est essayer c'est déjà pratiquement
terminée dame g6 il refile à le refuser
final de tout en y veut absolument voilà
ils gobent avec la dame et gardens adam
toujours c'est dur ça parce qu'après les
i après il peut toujours simplifier la
finale peut-être même de roy sera
gagnante et les manigances
c'est un cauchemar comme on dit oui mais
il y aura pas de finale d'oran stéphane
de toute façon et on va voir
voilà alors non l'allopathie vite
n'avons pas si vite remettons la dame
noire en les six dames le 3 c'est encore
bien joué il a mis la tour devant la
dame ont laissé bien débrouillé c'est
maintenant la tour menace d'aller soit
en russie ce soit en 8,6 en gagner un
pack dans la dame et le pion à 6,1 et le
curage si c'est le pion à 620 c'est
terrible éventuellement on peut passer à
8 sur la fameuse huitième rang j'ai donc
là les trois rangées et noir sont très
sensibles à 6e la 7e et la 8e et donc la
tour blanche placée comme l'éden c'est à
dire devant la dame c'est idéal est très
très forte
et puis les noirs peuvent pas faire des
chèques pour y faire un championnat
n'ont pas le temps de prendre le corps
rien faire parce qu'on apprend rien
faire et mat bien avant dame g63 fils
tour l'a bien vu sa force vladislav à
jouer le top 6 maintenant il affaiblit
la septième rangée
c'est plus pareil c'est plus cher mais
pas même peiné à mes chèques
c'est drôle non mais là la position noir
s'effondre complètement
moi j'évite die welt échec vous et de
voir la petite manoeuvre technique dames
c'est cet échec est maintenant il ya
plus rangée vite puisque sinon il y
aurait deux des huit échecs je croise et
je ne dis pas de bêtises
ah oui qui seraient terminés alors on
peut montrer la varende stéphane six ans
sur manger vite si on veut continuer
comme ça il ya dam des huit échecs dames
des 8es après deux tours et fuite qui
semble quasi forcée madame dessins
qu'ils noueraient jet set n'aurait pas
été pardonnés tout reproche et cissé
chaque tour prendre dame échecs qui ont
été programmées chez sept îles font pas
je vous tour f 800 ils se posent les
trois fuites il faut jouer à manger
c'est le roi g7 ici il a simplement
j'aurais de la nausée cnt j'aurai cette
année mais plus près ces vieux la donne
le futur est peut-être la tour va
prévenir sur la facture est ce possible
ces projets 8 peut-être tout simplement
les blanches jouaient tous est une pièce
blanche sont très bien placés ici pour
contrôler ses suprises à l'entente du
grand blanc et or noir pendant alors ça
aurait été très problématique pour eux a
dit stop
mentalement c'est loin tout pensé de la
finale frictions qui résultaient après
l'échangé oui la finale d'options je ne
sais pas je sais difficile difficile est
difficile mais je pense que les noirs
devrait devrait tenir ces spéciales
s'est facilement peut-être même qu'il
serait bien peut-être grillé pour faire
attention donc la toto rêve cette dame
c'est si ça va ça c'est pas mal placé là
non mais là c'est fini la s'affrontent
inhumain voilà la dame quand il a lu pas
mal attaque la dame g6 et le pion 6
balles perdues c'est sûr voilà c'est
tout simplement terme hills est
maintenant après enrique pato n'ont pas
tout de suite fait d'abord un échec
oui aïe le travail à tanger 6e travail
assailli français alors là là il est
maintenant il peut échanger tout s'il ya
une variante pour doute où ils échangent
tout collectif de clients je parie qu'il
échangera traître et c'est depuis un an
contre 1 ici il peut foncer adam avec
dans la finale de roi et pendant que
laurent noir va essayer de combler le
pion de plus laurent blanc va prendre
les pions de votre corps est en fait
c'est ce qu'on appelle une manoeuvre de
diversion manettes de 10/20
mais effectivement gretsch aucun n'a pas
envie de faire ça c'est l'europe
il reprend le deuxième tube ses cinq ans
d'existence la dernière et sport il veut
jouer touré fin essayer de mater vafc de
match mais il fait mater avant bien sûr
bien système à savoir que si les blancs
prennent l'option b 5
il pourrait y avoir peut-être un système
de pâtes peut-être c'est ça qu'ils
espèrent enjoint d'alger en sacrifiant
la tour oui peut-être une système de
partie fictive mais bon je crois que
c'est plus de l'escargot trust
oui d'autant plus qu'après tour h7 on
est là pour avec échec ici après tours
h7 est bien trash et quatre abandons
parce que là c'est pire que tout on perd
le toit avait quelque chose puisque là
on perd tous à vos héros est fluide la
vente la plus solide et d'un engagement
qu'il a écrites on est mal je crois on m
a nom n'est pas maintenant je me perds
la tête quand même de faire la toilette
après un roi ici il abandonne ici s'il
avait joué au roi est fluide tv
d'amabilités shaikh
il y avait des mammifères g 8 et g
or cette recette forcé il avait cet état
rue bessette qui récupère la tour
souvent at on aussi permis en quatre
autres je le pense oui je pense que l'on
peut aussi y faire plus en plus sûrement
matter where we non mais ça n'a aucun
intérêt
justement à une bourde et plus à noter
que ça rappelle énormément la partie de
l'état ou contre lautié le roi est
faible toute la partie électro avec dame
et tour arrive justement le faire
tourner et vous pouvez revoir ça dans
les archives c'est l'émission
après le deuxième tour oui toi on
croisait des premiers taux entre les
deux hommes est tout à fait prêt alors
surprise je crois le premier tour y est
c'est la surprise
tout à fait l'art est invoqué quand même
pas un nouveau né c'est vrai dernier
venu puisque finalement ce jeune plein
de monde pour l'instant on a
relativement peu de surprises de
vraiment grosse surprise quand alors on
va passer justement pronostics
ouais pronostique que puisque nous avons
luc bergeon ce qui est là avec nous
winky très fort notre effort en
pronostics je crois qu'il a d'ailleurs
il a mis des mises chez les bookmakers
anglais donc adams a nom de l'udc pour
qui a dû parier et qu'elles sont à ton
avis des points forts et les points
faibles de ces de jouer un con anand
évidemment elle favori je pense de tout
le monde c'est probable qu'ils gagnent
cette partie néanmoins bon adams est un
joueur solide il aura peut-être sa
chance peut-être que peut-être un jour
en semi rapides cette finale oui c'est
improbable parce qu'un homme c'est quand
même très très solide alors ces deux
joueurs qui ont les nerfs extrêmement
solide
adams et à nombre on se rappellera
qu'ils se rencontrent en finale à
groningen en 98 oui c'est qu'alain da
veiga nissan honda vais gagner mais
alors à je ne sais plus rien dit de
cette partage est très importante c'est
que ces demi finales pour la première
fois on se jouer en quatre parties et
non par quatre parties longues
oui enfin c'était pareil la dernière
fois aussi william levada ventes en mai
par rapport au tour précédent rapport
aux tours précédents effectivement ça
change tout ceux des plus deux parties
ces quatre voilà ce qui laisse justement
d'ailleurs beaucoup moins de chance agri
tchouk contre shirov ah oui puisque
quatre partis c'est deux fois plus dur
que d'autres partis quand on est
outsider oui mais oui il est plus que 2
fois 2 dont vont pas rentrer on peut
dire que je cherche une grand favori
contre cliff shaw oui et c'est mon
favori même face j'espère qu'il va qui
gagnerait à noter que si chirac gagne le
championnat du monde ça va poser de gros
problèmes parce qu'il faut rappeler que
c'est qu'ils savaient pas du kram unique
oui il méritait de jouer le 2 juin au
canal du monde contre kasparov
il a été lésé
contre le kasparov et donc ça serait que
justice qu'ils gagnent gagne ici et pour
revenir un match revanche je l'espère
contre contre chronique entre crémines
maintenant peut-être idir et non j'ai
déjà battu il faut qu'ils se qualifient
alors on ne sait pas ce qu'ils vont dire
en tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que le
système de la fide et vous changera
probablement l'année prochaine
oui donc petit avantage pour shirov
effectivement dans la mesure où adam
s'annonce va être un match très
éprouvant pour les nerfs
vraisemblablement il y aura des semi
rapides on compare que l'on est loin le
site sur lequel on peut suivre ces
partis quand même si oui alors c'est le
site web fi des points comme vous avez
un lien qui vous donne accès aux parties
en direct et en anglais c'est en anglais
vous pouvez également les suivre sur un
français à libération qui lie la
rubrique des chèques de libération doit
qu'à remercier qui fait un résumé très
très bien il ya également europe échec
très bon on peut les mentionner qu'ils
font un chat en live tous les matins à
partir de 9 heures
donc pour les lève tôt ou pour les gens
qui travaillent effectivement vous
pouvez aller sur le site et chaque point
comme pour lancer des sites qu'on
conseille quoi on peut plus rien oui en
français il ya libération et rambouillet
chez europe échec
et sinon
si l'on se rend compte alors luc ton
pronostic ces annonces cherche des tubes
shirov peut-être des pronostics de score
c'est en quatre parties à ce corps des
signes rapide dans des dommages
oui comme j'ai dit je pense que dans le
match à nantes contre la dame sait il y
aura des semi rapide parce que c'est là
que ça déterminera ça va être très chaud
shirov je pense qu'il y aura peut-être
c'est bien chez rob n'y aura pas de
match
bon tout en donnant rendez vous voilà à
samedi pour le résultat de ces deux demi
finales ça va être très chaud et donc
merci alex bergez d'avoir été avec nous
ce soir et à samedi